first off happy thanksgiving everyone
shout out to turkey
tommy gobbler's back and he wants to
hear what you turkeys are thankful for
charles you got to stop
i don't gobble understand people but
charles gobble dude gobble gobble gobble
your tail feather is caught in the
gobble door thank you gobble wait what
oh i think your feathers are ripping
gobble
gobble
oh
santiago the floor is yours thank you
okay here's everyone's itineraries for
thanksgiving at my place i know a lot of
your families are out of town and you
just want to relax but i think we'll all
enjoy ourselves more if we rigidly stick
to the schedule whoa did you assign us
individual bathroom break times keep
asking questions about it sergeant your
slot is after skully's hi santiago down
short toilet sorry it's just that my dad
is coming into town and he can be a
little
uptight oh santiago's calling someone up
tight that can't be good he's not crazy
he's just the kind of guy who arranges
the money in his wallet according to
serial number yeah
that kind of guy boyle are you set on
the turkey this year's bird will be as
moist no
as juicy as no as wet as you can well
just say it'll be good man it'll be good
man i've got a great thanksgiving plant
nikolaj has taken to food just like his
papa so i'm making an exotic spread if
it could fly or swim we're eating its
eggs well at the jeffers house it's not
just thanksgiving it's also ava's
birthday so we do it up huge i gotta
repair the parrot
that's a hot toy terry tried ten toy
stores i guess i'm the only one doing
this holiday right hitting the open road
with my bike
no family no friends no dinner
that sounds really dark
thank you well everyone's plans seem
lovely oh hitchcock and i didn't say
hers how unfortunate
unbutton your pants and take off your
shoes cause there's gonna be a doink
load of sodium at freedom feast 2017. we
begin where all great stories begin in
the quaint little town a french fry
village after that we're gonna move our
adventure over to cheeseburger mountain
which consists you guessed it of turkey
burgers i'm kidding it's cheeseburgers
this is kind of just stuffing you can
avoid that but it's attached to the
thanksgiving turkey theme cause i was
thinking about that a lot up in the jail
as you all know i hate thanksgiving the
pilgrims were murderers and turkey
tastes like napkins i just hope that no
amy's feel bad that i was chosen over
amy
actually captain asked me first but i
had plans teddy brewed a thanksgiving
pilsner and it's bottling day bottling
day why'd you come in at all
happy turkey day yes right out of the
gate what what's going on we're playing
boyle bingo thanksgiving edition
everyone filled out their cards with
possible charles related scenarios first
bingo gets a hundred bucks i had boyle
calls at turkey day in the center square
boyle explains that they ate lobsters at
the first thanksgiving they did back in
that time they called lobster's ocean
bugs and i'll just mark it off for you i
think i got the winning card here boyle
tells us that he played pocahontas in
his third grade play all the girls were
too big this is a fun one boyle says
gobble gobble gobble well now that i
know you want me to say that i'll just
say it with two gobbles
gobble god it just it just sounds right
that way ah i don't like this game
boyle objects to boyle bingo come on
guys boyle says come on guys that's tufa
terry well guess what i can spoil your
little game by sitting over here quietly
all day and doing nothing
oh
ah
anybody have boyle falls on the floor
no one that's a victory that's a victory
for boyle
boom
boys
okay we're running out of time what do
you guys like better classic bishop hat
fold or
crown fold now the crown is more showy
but the bishop hath has a certain
dignity i'll kill myself if it's not the
crown fold oh okay thanks
sometimes you have to pretend to care
about napkins to stop hearing about
napkins sorry i'm late
guys how to get my ax sharpened why do
you have an ax also nice x thank you
it's for the turkey so i can chop its
head off when it gets here chop its head
off i ordered a live turkey it's being
delivered cause you know what they say
the yummiest turkey is the one that just
died in your hands charles you can't
kill an animal in here that's horrible
it's disgusting we won't let you do it
right amy it's getting late don't make a
mess relax it's not the first turkey
i've killed in a friend's bathtub it is
he
hello raymond ready to go to dinner yes
but i have some unfortunate news about
our pie
it was thrown away no are you serious
and i know who did it who you all
bragged about your thanksgiving plans
why
you were
compensating trying to cover up your
dark
secrets but there was one other person
who was also over compensating
you kevin even better than a plain scone
clean school
i should have known you were lying
there's nothing better than a plain
scone this is ridiculous is it how the
pie was disposed of placed gently with
two hands inside the bin that's exactly
how you always throw away garbage it is
there's only one thing i still can't
figure out why'd you do it because it's
disgusting oh my that pie is an
abomination it has beef suet and apple
seeds in it why it's a walnut pie if we
brought that to my family's house they
would have said something i was trying
to protect you why didn't you just tell
me the truth
because i love our annual trips to
saratoga springs the two of us driving
in silence looking at the barren trees
it's perfect i
didn't want to lose that
i'm sorry i don't know why we can't
still make the drive next year we just
don't have to buy the pie a trip with no
purpose
raymond
so this is kind of a play on your
typical thanksgiving dinner for turkey
we have the peking duck with a veggie
samosa stuffing the potatoes are the
empanadas with an ethiopian lentil stew
gravy and for dessert some seasonal
gelatin cups okay ran out of money
they're from one hitchcock got his
colonoscopy bon appetit
i'm here i'm here
finally something to actually be
thankful for what are you wearing
santiago said to dress up so well you
look beautiful
that's my thing now i'm just owning it
okay
before we eat nope not doing that again
move could you pass through get that
hand near me again you're gonna lose it
okay duke boyle your turkey's here all
right let's do this
pretty cool huh i feel like dexter i
think i never actually saw the show
billboard gave me nightmares charles are
you crazy no i don't want to watch a
living animal die and then consume its
flesh how is this different than eating
a turkey that's been killed in a factory
because i don't have to see that it's
called living a denial you [ __ ] gina i
know it seems cruel but it's a swift
death one painless chop removes the head
that doesn't sound so bad and this
decapitated corpse only flops around for
like
a half an hour you know what you won't
be able to go through with this if i
give this little guy a name he's now
nikolaj oh that's my son's name go ahead
cut nikolaj's throat sorry gina but we
need a turkey and you're the only one
complaining i don't like it either it's
not a fair fight give the bird a gun
let's see what happens sarge this must
bother you too yeah but eating a big
drumstick on thanksgiving makes terry
feel like a king sorry but it's five
against two wait you assume hitchcock
and i want to eat that turkey yeah thank
you charles do what you need to do copy
that no hold up rosa get the bird on it
i'll stand here and sacrifice my life to
charles's bloodlust i'm not gonna kill
you gina
then you already lost
no where are you going hey you can run
but you can't hide the apartment will
run red with the blood of nikolaj please
stop calling him that you know you said
you always wanted to have a big family
thanksgiving i had five brothers three
sisters four aunts and twelve cousins
who spent every holiday together i had
the kind of family that you dream of
oh are you done that seemed like a
really mean place to stop but you're
taking a long pause when we all were
together huge mess i can't tell you how
many holidays i spend in the er but
that's what it means to have a big
family
like this one
oh
well thank you victor and apparently my
family's a lot bigger than i thought how
many half-sisters did you say i have dad
i only told you about the sisters come
on roger i want to apologize to you for
being so defensive about you wanting to
pay for the wedding i'm sorry too it was
stupid
i was just feeling insecure because i
did take the watch i was gonna say
because you saw my penis through my
underpants but the watch yeah sure i was
thinking uh if you want to pay for the
wedding it will be fine but we can't
split it
it's up to you
that seems fair
you're a good dude come here give me a
hug
you mean hug me hug me bring it in
jake it's happening the weird but good
dad hug oh it's magical
best thanksgiving ever
yep dad your gown's riding up oh it's
out oh it's out
come on guys it's getting late open the
door not until you promise to let this
little turkey live out the rest of his
life with rosa what why can't i live
with you i'm an ideas man all right
that's it you left me no choice
there we go
thanks
now give us the bird gladly whoop
not that bird don't take another step
this ends now i am so sorry girl great
party but uh uh all right there it is be
free noble bird be free fly away fly to
freedom gina turkeys can't fly
why's he looking at me like that
nobody make any sudden moves man those
talons are super sharp huh i think it's
a freaking dinosaur
[Applause]
you